merci Lear merci d'avoir été là alle on
va passer tout de suite aux invités du
soir et un témoignage très fort on va
recevoir Mostapha Salan pour un
témoignage poignance mapha c'est le
chauffeur de taxi qui a été pris en
otage par le terroriste de l'attentat du
marché de Noël en décembre 2018 un
attentat qui a fait 5 morts et 11
blessés il a décidé de se raconter son
histoire dans un livre avec l'excellent
Frédéric Ploquin qui va être avec lui
vous allez voir cette histoire je vous
le dis vous allez être dans une fiction
on va rentrer là 15 minutes dans une
fiction c'est un truc de fou euh
regardez l'extrait du JT et il seront
avec nous juste aprs merci ce soir-là
dans ces rues autour du marché de Noël
de Strasbourg un terroriste fait 5 morts
et 11 blessé quelques centaines de
mètres plus loin le destin de ce
chauffeur de taxi va croiser celui du
terroriste shérif shekat s'engouffre
dans le taxi et force Mostapha Salan à
démarrer durant 15 longues minutes
Mostapha Salan imagine toutes les fins
possibles l'accident la fusillade la
bombe le chauffeur de taxi fonce
prévenir la police qui trouvera et tuera
le terroriste 2 jours plus tard merci
d'être avec N merci à vous deux merci
Mostapha d'être là chauffeur de taxi qui
a conduit le terroriste de l'attentat de
de Strasbourg c'est un truc de fou merci
en tout cas d'être avec nous et merci de
vouloir témoigner ce soir merci à
l'excellent Frédéric Frédéric poquin qui
vient nous voir souvent Frédéric grand
reporter et ce livre aux éditions PL il
est incroyable 15 minutes pour sauver ma
vie bah là vous allez être dans 15
minutes d'un récit
incroyable Frédéric comment vous êtes
rencontré avec Mostapha déjà on a un
certain nombre de d'amis commun on s'est
découvert un certain nombre d'amis
commun la plupart sont policiers parce
que mostaapha chauffeur de taxi ancien
vigile de boîte de nuit connaît
énormément de policier à Strasbourg et
moi je travaille sur la police depuis 40
ans donc déjà ça nous a fait des des
passerelles on va dire c'est comme ça
qu'il est arrivé vers moi on l'a
recommandé et nousous sommes rencontrés
et j'ai commencé à faire parler à
écouter mostafha et en fait il a
accouché de ce récit absolument
incroyable de ce h cl dans quel état
Mustapha quand vous l'avez rencontré bah
écoutez j'ai j'ai l'impression que ce
livre ce livre lui a permis pour la
première fois parce qu'en fait il s'est
terré après l'attentat ça a été très
difficile pour lui ça été une une
période beaucoup plus compliquée qu'on
imagine quand on n'est prise en otage
pendant comme ça pendant 15 minutes on
on enen sort pas indemne il s'est terré
d'autant que vous le verrez en lisant le
livre c'est grâce à lui que le
terroriste est identifié donc à partir
de là et et en même temps et en même
temps la police ne le protège pas
forcément comme il faut donc bref il y a
eu il y a eu 4 ans très très difficiles
pour lui et et là je pense qu'à travers
ce ce récit voilà c'est c'est aussi
c'est aussi celui d'une reconstruction
mais mais avant tout moi ce qui m'a
scotché c'est ce face- à faceace ce
Hulot finalement entre entre un
républicain parce que entre deux
musulmans aussi il faut il faut le dire
parce qu'ils sont tous les deux
musulmans de manière différente l'un est
républicain l'autre est assez antifrance
celui qui s'assoie derrière lui qui
s'installe de force dans son taxi et qui
le prend en otage et qui très rapidement
tac lui met comme ça une arme dans le
dos
derrièrea est costaud solide mais
justement 15 minutes pour sa
pour sauver sa vie pour sauver ma vie
mais pour sauver sa vie pour sauver pour
sauver nos vies parce que j'estime que
moi oui parce que j'estime que le combat
de Mostapha à ce moment-là dans ce dans
ce taxi ce qu'il fait pour essayer de
neutraliser cet homme c'est aussi pour
nous sauver nous parce que l'homme
l'individu en question a pour objet a
pour objectif d'aller au commissariat de
Strasbourg et de tuer le maximum de
policiers mapha vous avez conduit donc
le terroriste de l'attente à Strasbourg
deoire de votre livre c'était juste
après qu'il ait commis l'attentat du
marché de Noël oui donc je suis euh dans
dans son siage donc le je suis la
dernière personne qui va avec qui il va
échanger oui et il il venait de tuer le
la dernière victime qui était un un
touriste thaïlandais qui visitait
Strasbourg qui était venu pour visiter
Strasbourg et et donc Comand moi
j'arrive sur cette place là il était
caché derrière une
camionette en train d'attendre et moi je
une fois que mes mes clients sont
descendus euh ils ont laissé la porte
arrière ouverte et d'un d'un seul coup
je vois un un individu arriver avec un
regard noir la main dissimulée sur sa
veste il arrive il s'installe dans la
voiture il ferme la porte il me dit
dépêche-toi de rouler vite ramène-moi
dans un quartier qui était à proximité
de de Strasbourg qui s'appelle nudorp et
donc moi je vois euh j'ai quand même une
expérience cette fibre autant que à
l'époque j' dans une autre vie j'étais
physionomiste mais et aussi karateka
donc je connais ce genre de de type
comment comment leur réaction et je me
suis dit celui-là il est pour moi ce
soir euh et et la masse qu'il avait en
dessous de sa deodoun euh pour moi
c'était un sac qui venait sans doute
piquer un touriste américain anglais et
je me suis dit bon c'est pas grave je
vais lu je vais l'amener plus loin et je
vais m'expliquer avec lui j'ai
l'habitude et et donc il était très
agressif il bougeit dans tous les sens
et en même temps les il transpirait et
ça m'interpelle et tout de suite j'ai
dis bon je vais démarrer et donc lui il
me demande de rouler très très vite et
je lui dit je peux pas doucement parce
qu'il y a il y a beaucoup de il y a
beaucoup de beaucoup de gens c'est une
place elle est noire de monde et
j'essaie de comprendre j'essaie de
essayer de décortiquer ce ce problème là
qu'est-ce qu'il a qu'est-ce qui pourquoi
il demande de rouler vite et et un
moment donc c'est lui qui fait
l'itinéraire et à un moment il me dit
bon j'ai dit Monsieur donnez-moi votre
votre adresse il me dit non non je te
donne pas mon adresse mais roule je dis
je vais te guider et donc on prend une
une route et on commence à à rouler une
grande route qui est droite et on
commence à rouler à ce moment-là et il
me dit tu parles l'arabe je dis non non
moi je je parle l'arabe oui bien sûr
mais euh il me dit tu est-ce que tu tu
es musulman euh j'ai dit oui oui je suis
musulman il me dit ok d'accord rou et je
dit je vois qu' tu es pas bien qu'est-ce
qui se passe il me dit
j'ai rien à te dire tu roules je d de
rouler tu roules et donc on est à peu
près à 200 m de là où je l'ai pris et il
m'a une patate chaude en me disant je
viens de faire un attent à Strasbourg je
viens de tuer des personnes je crois que
j'ai j'ai tué des musulmans j'ai tiré
sur des militair je crois que j'en ai
aussi tué des militaires je suis blessé
il me dit à partir de C là tu vas plus
nulle part tu vas rester avec moi on va
aller mourir ce soir ensemble et donc il
me met l'arme en dessous il me dit fais
le malin je
t'allume calme-toi range ton arme et on
d'accord moi je suis là je vais t'aider
je vais faire mon maximum je vais
t'emmener là tu veux il me dit vas-y
roule donc on roule il commence à
revendiquer par rapport à ce qui ce qui
se passe en Syrie en Irak euh et dans
les autres pays il me dit est-ce que tu
es d'accord avec eux euh j'ai d d'accord
avec qui il me dit oui avec eux c'est
c'est mes crayons non moi je suis pas
d'accord avec eux j'ai rien j'ai rien à
j'ai j'ai rien être d'accord avec eux
dit si si toi ça ça se voit que tu es
d'accord avec eux non non et donc je
continue et à un moment il commence à à
poser d'autres questions disons est-ce
que je fais ma prière est-ce que je fais
mon Ramadan est-ce que je
euh je pratique correctement mon islam
et je dis oui moi j'ai pas de problème
je pratique mon Islam dans ça
inagré dans son ensemble donc j'ai moi
j'ai j'ai pas de j'ai pas de souci à ce
à ce niveau-là et donc on fait ce
circuit là
et je vois qui qui transpire qui qui
vraiment qu'il est pas bien il me montre
sa main gauche qui là o ça saigne parce
qu'elle a été touchée auparavant par par
des militaires et on arrive pas très
loin du commissariat il reste à peu près
900 m du commissariat il me dit tu
tournes à gauche tu tu peux pas y aller
tout droit tu prends à droite et tu vas
direction le commissariat et on va au
commissariat et je me suis dit siil va
au commissariat c'est pour là pour finir
le travail donc moi je me suis fixé une
règle dans dans ma tête j'ai dit s'il
veut aller tuer du policier on va se
jeter tous les deux dans un canal qui
passe juste à côté du commissariat et je
vais en finir il y a une pression en fa
de compte on est on est dans un dans un
avion de chasse on n'est pas prêt à à je
dirais à à être làdedans il y a y a
tellement d'informations qui arrivent en
même temps sous armes et je dis à un
moment si les
les policiers arrivent on sera éliminé
tous les deux donc c'est quelque chose
aussi que qui me qui m'interpelle c'est
quelque chose qui qui g dans dans un
coin de ma tête et et à ce
moment-là il a mal il reste à peu près
700 m du commissariat il a mal il
commence à à hurler en me disant j'ai
mal il faut que tu me Soignes euh tu as
de quoi me soigner je dis oui oui pas de
problème on va où est-ce que tu veux que
j'aille à droite à à gauche je continue
non d'abord tu vas me soigner après on y
va au commissariat et donc on on
s'engouffre dans une ruelle et là on
avance et à moment je fais une marche
arrière je me posose donc il y a une
conversation qui se fait à l'intérieur
qui est assez assez Durre et
est raconter dans le livre je laisserai
découvrir dans le livre et et à ce
moment-là euh le téléphone sonne et
c'est un ami à moi qui qui m'appelle il
me dit où est-ce que tu es je dis écoute
je suis avec mon dernier client je vais
encaisser et j'arrive et je te ramène la
voiture et j'ai dis au terroriste voilà
moi je peux pas rester avec toi je dois
y aller je dois ramener la voiture à mon
collègue et je te laisse là il me fait
descendre de la voiture il me met l'arme
s le ventre il me dit tu fais le malin
je t'allume avec quoi tu vas me soigner
maintenant je dis voilà je sors un
paquet de mouchoir de
l'eau donc j'ai la le réflexe de lui
mettre sur le brasù il saigne comme ça
je sais que tant que karatékaa quand
quelqu'un est est touché quelque part et
il a il est concentré sur la douleur et
je me suis dit voilà je vais appuyer là
où ça fait mal et donc je vois cette
masse là je ou là où je je bouge pas je
dis Mustapha n'y va pas trop parce que
sinon ça va exploser parce que dans le
circuit il me parle de
Grenade je lui pose la bouteille d'eau
le paquet de mouchoir à un moment
d'inattention lui il rebaisse l'arme au
niveau de sa ceinture commence à prendre
les mouchoir je dis ça va je vais te
laisser là et au moment où il prend ça
dure 2 secondes je monte dans la voiture
j'accélère et je pars je fais à peu près
150 m je me retourne je vois qu'il est
en train de prendre les les mouchoirs je
prends la direction du commissariat je
fais le 17 le 17 ne répond pas direction
le commissariat je toque j'arrive parce
que là le rideau était fermé il y avait
une alerte et je donne les des
informations de ce type là ça dure à peu
près 10 minutes 10 minutes après ça
commence à tirer dans tous les sens à
l'extérieur et en fin de compte il s'est
nettoyé il est en train de revenir par
un chemin qui qui est assez assez secret
qui est en dessous de l'autoroute et il
a il a été intercepté par deux policiers
quand ils ont entendu mon appel et et
derrière il y a des échanges voilà
l'histoire à peu près parce que ce qui
ce ouais oui moi j'ai j'ai discuté 40
heures avec lui he pour reconstituer
l'histoire donc là vous en avez un petit
aperçu effectivement c'est un petit peu
mais juste juste une chose qui est
intéressante je trouve c'est que bon
effectivement il arrive au commissariat
euh c'est lui qui qui donne le nom qui
enfin qui donne les éléments il connaît
pas il connaît pas le nom de ce
terroriste et d'ailleurs il ne veut pas
on ne on ne le nomme pas dans le dans le
livre c'est volontaire euh Mustapha n'a
jamais voulu lui donner un nom parce
qu'en fait il veut pas lui donner une
existence il veut pas que le terroriste
il a raison devienneent le héros comme
c'est arrivé dans certain nombre
d'attentats vous av demandé son prénom
tout ça non non non en fin de compte
j'ai une chose que j'ai compris c'est
que je ne jamais contrarier un
adversaire parce que ça je sais comment
ça fonctionne et surtout quand c'est de
trouver une solution donc c'est d'abord
observer analyser et réagir ça je sais
faire
mais aucun moment je devais le
contrarier ou lui faire la morale
d'accord un primo c'est c'est rester
longtemps avec lui c'est s'exposer avec
les policiers qui sonans doute à un
moment ils vont arriver qu' vont avoir
l'alerte en disant qu'il est monté dans
un avec un chauffeur de taxi il est
parti dans avec un un taxi et pour moi
il faut que je me débarrasse au plus
vite de ce type là plus je suis exposé
plus la mort est au bout mais c'est ça
qui est terrible dans le hclos c'est que
par exemple normalement vous vous dites
la police va venir me sauver mais là
c'est pas ça parce que lui il est dans
sa voiture il conduit doucement il se
dit si la police arrive bah qu'est-ce
qu'il va faire lui il va sortir son arm
il va leur tirer dessus on va mourir
tous les deux donc tout le long c'est un
face- à faceace et à un moment donné on
passe devant la Grande Mosquée de
Strasbourg et le terroriste lui dit bah
fais ta prière maintenant tu vas mourir
il y a une espèce de tension comme ça
qui monte et à la fin à la fin c'est il
va pouvoir grâce à quelques petits
indices permettre à la police
d'identifier ce terroriste et donc il va
être retrouvé un peu plus tard on va pas
tout raconter maintenant et ce qui va
être assez ce qui moi m'a beaucoup
troublé dans le récit qu'il m'a fait
c'est que donc après avoir apporter sur
un plateau finalement le terroriste à à
la police il va se retrouver alors
est-ce que c'est parce qu' il est Arab
j'en sais rien mais le lendemain il va
se retrouver dans la situation quasiment
de suspect Mustapha et ça je pense que
c'est quelque chose qui a beaucoup
contribué à le à le
casser moi je trouve que c'est ou c'est
ça qui est incroyable si vous nous
rejoignez à 21h9 on est en direct c'est
que vous êtes passé de témoins vous avez
ét en témoin victime pu après CTA fini
suspect c'est ça qui est incroyable
racontez-nous ça par c'est fou et en fin
de compte moi j'étais dans un désarroi
complet quand quand quand j'étais au
commissariat de j'arrive à 20h15 jusqu'à
5h du matin je repars chez moi le l tout
seul tout seul par accompagné tout seul
dans la nuit à au volant de son taxi
c'est déjà déjà c'est un petit peu
curieux comme façon de traiter les
victimes oui et donc une faut arriver à
la maison le lendemain je suis assailli
de de journalistes et je décide de
partir de chez moi et il y aller chez la
famille et et à ce moment-là moi j'étais
pas bien j'étais vraiment si vous voulez
dans un état second parce que on n'est
pas préparé à ça surtout et je demande
de l'aide justement s'il y a une cellule
de crise justement pour s rendre parce
qu'il y a des psychologues des
psychiatres et donc on m'oriente vers
des psychologues et des psychiatres ça
se passe très très bien sauf que le le
psychiatre il en a déduit que j'avais
besoin de la sécurité j'avais besoin
d'être être entouré en sécurité étant
donné que le terroriste il est toujours
dans la nature et à ce moment-là on
m'oriente vers vers le commissariat vers
le le chef de la police afin de pouvoir
me mettre à disposition une protection
et et aussi
m'aider justement pour ma famille et
cetera les choses ne vont pas se
dérouler quand j'arrive donc je suis de
nouveau réinterrogé par par par la
police et donc là c'est plus la police
de Strasbourg judiciaire donc c'est la
police antiterro qui qui arrive et là
ils me disent avec le circuit que vous
nous avez donné hier soir euh il y a
quelque chose qui va pas on veut on
comprend pas on va recommencer to à zé
en gros en gros é je veux dire le le
c'est c'est un c'est un policier qui
arrive de Paris qui a pas vécu la nuit
avec avec eux qui l'a pas interrogé la
veille qui dit c'est troublant votre
histoire peut-être qu'en fait vous
attendiez vous en fait il pense dans sa
tête que peut-être il attendait le
terroriste à l'endroit où il était garé
et donc là c'est c'est là c'est là où se
passe une voilà une espèce de
renversement de situation qui va rendre
la vie très difficile pour le le film il
est trop trop beau pour être vrai comme
on dit exactement donc un truc ouais il
finit son circuit mortifère il arrive il
trouve le taxi il monte c'est une
Mercedes noire on sait pas qui est
làdedans s'il y en a plusieurs si a les
armes ils sont plein le coffre est plein
d'armes donc on sait pas donc et c'est
normal je la
critique voilà mais ils ont le droit de
faire leur travail c'est c'est normal
mais sauf c'est que entre témoins
victimes il y a deux séparation et là
j'étais vraiment une victime et j'avais
besoin d'un soutien d'une assurance et
finalement je je pars mais très très
loin mais ça c'est dans le livre j' j'en
parle qu'est-ce qui s'est passé après
vous avez cru mourir ou pas dit je vais
ah oui moi j'ai dit revoir à mes enfants
j'ai dit oui oui j'ai dit revoir mes
enfants moi j'ai fait la prière avant de
mourir à trois fois et je voyais ma
famille défiler quand il m'a annoncé
envoyer des messages à votre famille non
c'est c'est dans son voilà dans son dans
son mental il arrête pas de parler le le
gars derrière il arrête pas de l' enfin
c'est un moulin à parole et pendant ce
temps-là Mustapha essaie de se
concentrer et il fait bon il fait ses
prières il revoit défiler son fils sa
fille il a d'ailleurs il a un fils
policier il voit un peu défiler il voit
un peu défiler tout le monde il dit au
revoir en fait il pense qu'il va mourir
parce que il voit pas l'issue il y a pas
d'issue de ce h cl à ce moment-là il
voit bien et puis ce ce qui est terrible
je trouve c'est je veux dire aussi bien
je disais tout à l'heure Mustapha c'est
c'est un républicain et derrière il a
quelqu'un qui déteste toutes les valeurs
de la France donc il et et qu' le dit et
qui essaie de lui et qu'il le teste et
qui lui dit mais tu penses comm moi sûr
il pouvit pas le contredire voilà il
pouvait pas le contredire donc c'est
assez compliqué de ce point de vue là
aussi merci F merci Mostapha merci
Frédéric Ploquin 15 minutes pour sauver
ma vie merci d'avoir été avec nous tout
de suite c'est le monastère C on aura le
scoop de palska la semaine prochaine
c'est très c'est pas ouf non
plus demain demain demain pass à 18h50
et